hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
jacqueline back yet again with my
favorite person around this time of year
mr mark ellis
well i used to be your favorite person
around this time of year i i committed a
transgression against jacqueline that i
felt like we should open the show with
just uh just to get the air out there
and i'm very curious i'm by the way
y'all he teased me with this been on
pins and needles so
mark tell the tale so i was in new york
um the last five days doing a lot of
different
jobs and shows uh joel mears our beloved
former editor-in-chief of rotten
tomatoes we i got to host the the final
panel that he was on as that title at
rotten tomatoes and we had a great time
talking about the upcoming book the
binge guide the ultimate guide to
television and joel came to one of my
stand-up shows we had a great time
pounding around and so we're having a
great week and then i decided to go to a
bar with a bunch of my friends on sunday
to watch football it's a chicago bar
jaclyn and this is where i'm going with
this is that jaclyn's a big packers fan
i was among chicagoans watching the
bears and they got a win over the
raiders and so the way you celebrate a
bears win is there's this awful liquor
that is based in chicago called milord
and everybody does a free milort shot
and so i did him a lord shot and i was a
chicago bear fan for about five minutes
towards the end of that game so i
apologize
and i hope this doesn't affect the rest
of the show today because we have a
great guest and a really fun series of
movies to talk about
i mean mark your
washington football team yes and we are
aligned for our hatred of the cowboys
and so we always have that it does feel
a little bit like you slept with my
ex-boyfriend not with my boyfriend like
if you were like in front of me
cheering for the bears there would be a
problem and i and i would have i would
have never done this this was done on
the sly it was just it was the cheap
hotel room of bars
and we we don't ever have to talk about
it again but i just wanted to let you
know i still support you and your cheese
head wearing brethren hey and we had a
great game on sunday and yes folks you
just came into rotten tomatoes as espn
but we're gonna switch it up and get
into halloween pretty quickly here
because it is halloween time and
halloween kills is now in theaters and
our guest this week is here to talk
about it along with the halloween
franchise ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna break down all of the films all
the timelines and
the various craziness that sort of got
kicked off after john carpenter's
seminal halloween from 1978. so
let's go ahead and get into it introduce
our guest today he is a screenwriter and
he wrote a little halloween film you
guys might remember called freaky which
is out now on hbo max and he has another
slasher in the works at ace called time
cut he's a massive halloween and slasher
fan everyone please welcome our
certified fresh guest mr michael kennedy
hello sir hey there thanks for having me
i appreciate you being here man i really
do feel we are in good halloween
hands and so
yeah so have you had a chance to look at
our ranking at rotten tomatoes because
this is another one of our ranking
episodes where we take the franchise let
the tomato meet her decide the good bad
and indifferent how are you feeling
about it are we right with this ranking
are we wrong with this ranking what are
you thinking about it
pretty spot on i would say in a lot of
ways
um
maybe one or two that deserve to be a
little bit higher but they're pretty
they're pretty correct and they're in
pretty good order as far as worst of the
best
i mean
the
mark uh is actually going to break down
for us the rankings and give us their
order and attempt to maybe give us a bit
of a synopsis
yeah let's go ahead mark if you can
please give us uh the various
particulars of this slasher uh classic
and
where rotten tomatoes ranked the various
installments halloween kicked off in
1978 and it's all about jamie lee curtis
plays laurie strode a babysitter and she
is being attacked and stalked and all
sorts of terror infused from michael
myers little michael myers there's
always just been something wrong with
this kid ever since he murdered his much
older sister and then we find out in
some iterations of halloween canon that
laurie is actually the sister of michael
myers other iterations have retconned
that but the bottom line is this if you
live in haddonfield illinois you might
want to airbnb on some tropical
destination during halloween because bad
things happen
at the hands of michael myers who hails
from haddenfield and so where we are
right now is halloween kills is now in
theaters and that's the sequel to the
2018 film halloween which acts as a
direct sequel to 1978's halloween now
you may be saying well barry there's the
curse and the revenge and all these
other halloween movies all of those have
been retconned and so now we just go
from halloween 1978 to halloween from
2018 but there are other halloween
movies that you can enjoy out there such
as halloween two which came out in 1981
and then you have halloween three which
has nothing to do with any of them that
season of the witch halloween four was
the return of michael myers and so on
and so forth and according to the tomato
meter it's still the og that is the
highest rated and boy is it certified
fresh 96
as far and away the lead there's only
one other halloween movie that is on the
fresh side of the tomato meter and that
would be you guessed it 2018's halloween
at 79 we currently as of this recording
don't have data on halloween kills but
we do know that the next highest rated
film is rotten in the series halloween
h2o from 1998 which was the return of
jamie lee curtis to the character of
laurie strode and that acts as a direct
sequel to halloween two from 1981. did
it lose anybody yet
halloween h2o is 52 percent and from
there we kind of get more and more
rotten halloween three season of the
witch is at 41
halloween two is 32 percent halloween
for the return of michael myers is 29
halloween the rob zombie reboot from
2007 is it 28
and then that sequel to 21 halloween
five the revenge of michael myers is 12
halloween resurrection
12 and halloween the curse of michael
myers
starring paul wood is at 9
and so they were getting bad and worse
and really bad there for a while but i
do
sort of lean towards our beloved guest
michael here i think a couple of those
movies jacqueline could stand to be a
little higher up on the tomato meter
yeah um
i
i i don't know how i feel about this i
just need to take a minute to assess the
fact that two of my obsessions before
the age of 20 paul rudd and josh
hartnett book in the bottom three
basically
of uh of halloween movies i'm very like
i'm very upset about this is that right
no halloween h2o is higher never mind
halloween h2o is higher so it almost
gets to fresh should be higher yeah
so josh hartnett had a good one it's
only paul rudd who you know any girl
that watched clueless was in love with
paul rudd and probably still is okay
i want to know about
you michael okay i know you i know you
told us you know
so far and different but just real quick
what is the one glaring jumping out at
you that needs to be higher
besides i guess h2o is that the one
you're saying uh
well there's you know the ones to me
that need to be
certified fresh i'll say
are
halloween h2o
um
i think uh did you say how or no i said
wow
he deserves so that movie i have friends
that made 2018 i actually think h2o is
the better of those two moves
shade okay
but i think h2o is a better is the
better version
h2o come out
in this day and age it would have been
received better by critics and fans
than it was in 1998.
um i think she explores a lot of very
similar themes in the 1998 movie and the
reason i actually think it's a better
movie is they spend the entire movie on
lori strode as opposed to deviating from
that character to
random characters that's um i think the
biggest problem with 2018 and i like the
2018 movie and i love
jamie lee curtis and i love judy greer
in it especially
but there's too much time away from the
strode girls
okay oh man i love that in 1990 the 1998
h2o it's all about jamie lee okay and i
think that's why that movie stands out
for me compare and comparatively and
deserves a higher rating guys i feel
like i'm going to get a lot of halloween
education because little little secret i
didn't watch any scary movies before i
started being sort of a professional
critic and we'll get into that later but
first perducy lucy how you doing ma'am
where do you fall on halloween where do
you fall on scary movies i
did not have not will not see any of
these films because i'm too scared i was
talking to michael yesterday and i was
like no
i am i'm i'm fascinated with like that
kind of you know dark stuff and spooky
stuff especially during halloween but
these movies really especially um
scary movies that have a root in the 70s
there's something creepier about that
kind of like 70s look and feel so i
remember seeing footage of halloween in
the 1978 version and being like held to
the no this is not happening because
that kind of like the film look and the
like
bad hair and bad outfits to me actually
makes it scarier
but
really quick i just realized because i
know michael you love the new film it's
tracking at 56
rotten
it's not official yet but
that to me
based off kind of the chatter i've seen
online that seems really low breaking
news michael how do you feel i think
it'll get a little bit higher too i
think it'll end up in the in the 60
range somewhere
um
i think it'll be below the last one but
i think i'll end up not certified fresh
but it'll end up fresh right there's a
difference yes and i appreciate you for
making that distinction mark have you
seen the new one yet
i have not had a chance to see the new
one yet i've been very busy cheering for
my new favorite team the chicago bears
and so oh my god have not been able to
do
halloween kills just yet but i am very
excited about
seeing it because we basically got left
off of that trailer before the pandemic
like right when the pandemic hit we saw
that that just like 15 second clip of of
lori strode yelling at the firefight
like don't go to that let him burn and
then it's like oh we gotta wait so much
longer to see this movie now so i'm just
so excited to finally get it out there
but i have good news for lucy because
the movie i agree with michael first of
all that h2o should be much much higher
i think that is a fresh film
bar none but i'm also going to support
and say that lucy's
maybe her introduction not into michael
myers but into the halloween franchise
not current halloween canon is halloween
three season of the witch because
it does play upon a lot more religious
themes there's a lot more obviously
which going on there's a lot of things
that are going on in that that it's it's
a fun horror movie as long as you don't
walk in with the expectations that
michael myers is going to show up
eventually and so i think there is a lot
of redeeming value to halloween three
seasons of the witch around this holiday
that we all celebrate by watching our
favorite spooky films so like i said
it's currently rotten it's 41
and i think it can get higher i i think
that movie deserves to be fresh i just
said it here
i agree
wow
okay let's not agree that was the other
movie i was going to mention it should
be certain
certified fresh season of the witch okay
season of the witch is not one for me
i'm with you guys on h2o and i have seen
i think i've seen two of the other
installments two or three i think i've
seen two or three of the other
installments but man i'm ready to get
into it so let's go ahead before we do
that um so mark
rightish
michael rightish is that correct on
rotten tomatoes on this one yeah okay
i'm saying no i'm saying that that
there's too many halloween movies that
are way too low on the tomatoes i could
agree with that too there's some that
deserve to be iron but not fresh
yeah basically the question is michael
and mark we have the same feeling about
it michael's just a much nicer human
being than i am so he's going to lean
towards yeah it's fine and i'm going to
be like no no no no you all got to get
the score up to fresh
okay i will say for the films that i
have seen
i am like
okay-ish
but i know that i need to see more of
these but honestly there's too many
hours in the day and that's why we have
this next person our review creation
manager tim ryan he's going to help fill
in the gaps that i have forgotten with
our favorite segment two minutes with
tim so brian please cue the music
when it comes to the halloween franchise
there's a lot to cover so we're gonna
focus on the peaks and valleys for now
let's set aside halloween kills the
newest entry in the franchise there have
been 11 films leading up to it of those
only two are fresh the original
halloween from 1978 is certified fresh
at 96 percent and halloween from 2018 is
certified fresh at 79
the lowest reviewed films in the series
are halloween the curse of michael myers
from 1995 which is rotten at nine
percent and tied at rotten at 12
are halloween five the revenge of
michael myers from 1989 and halloween
resurrection from 2002 and just as an
aside
halloween 3 season of the witch the only
film in the franchise not to feature
michael myers is rotten at 41 percent
although it does have something of a
cult following so it's safe to say that
by and large the halloween series has
been more of a popular success than a
critical one but what did some of the
critics have to say in a fresh review
for the original halloween roger ebert
of the chicago sun times wrote halloween
is an absolutely merciless thriller a
movie so violent and scary that yes i
would compare it to psycho on the other
hand in a rotten review for halloween
the curse of michael myers james barrard
nelly of realviews wrote needless to say
the gore level is high and the scare
level low
although not as low as the intelligence
level so anyway
jaclyn mark
it's halloween i guess everyone's
entitled to one good podcast back to you
folks
hey
you know what no matter what time of
year is two minutes with tim gets me in
the spirit can we just go ahead and say
that whatever that spirit has to be he
gets us there
man it's just crazy to think of how many
these they've made
uh let's go ahead and get into sort of
uh talking about the various films
favorite moments favorite characters all
right brian let's go ahead and
transition over to our movie talk
section
[Music]
so like if you're making the recipe of a
halloween movie and you've made the
recipe of a couple of horror movies now
what do you think are the ingredients
that go in there okay so the biggest two
or three
are simplicity
um the halloween movies that are the
most effective are the ones with the
simplest premise and setup um
halloween halloween h2o halloween 2018
halloween kills even i would even go as
far as say halloween two are all pretty
straightforward movies
that focus on character
um which is why we love them and why
they're effective
and the simplicity goes it goes the same
way with michael
he's simple in these movies he's you
know these are the movies where he's
essentially still pure evil
you know even though halloween two
introduces a sibling angle it's not
until the very end so it's essentially
just some guy in a mask walking around
terrorizing
people in a town and it's effective
um because you don't know anything about
it and i think those are the scariest
villains a lot of the time so simplicity
a strong strong strong adversary for the
killer
again all those movies start with jamie
lee curtis so lori strode obviously
icon
she's an icon
a character who is tough like she is
always works in fact halloween 4 is
effective because even though it's like
a little girl
it's a tough adversary which is why that
movie for me works and should be a
little higher in the tomato meter
and
i mean those are really the two main
ingredients you need for a really good
halloween i mean obviously john
carpenter score elevates it above most
slasher movies to just by existing
and
yeah that was really all you need to
make a really good halloween movie hey i
really yeah i like the settings yeah i
mean it's it's the real estate it's
location location location and these
movies continue to get inside of our
pathology because
we all think we're secure we want to
feel like we're secure in our own homes
and when laurie looks out the window in
that first halloween movie and just sees
this creep standing there by the laundry
it's like i don't feel safe anymore and
that just
that that acts as a prelude from
everything to from scream to where we
get a phone call and the calls are
coming from inside the house sort of
thing up to the strangers where again we
don't we know nothing about the
strangers we just see their head pop in
and we're like oh my god what the hell
is that so you can make it dead serious
like that you can have a wink and a nod
with it with something like you're next
but that is the the most chilling aspect
of this to me is that this guy really
wants to get in our house and we can't
stop him i'll also add in two
that you have to have a certain level of
sin and maybe this is the southern grew
up uh in a very domineering christian
household but a certain level of people
doing bad things like it's the thing
that randy talks about in scream which
is literally absolutely true if you grew
up in those type of households you
definitely understand
kids drinking kids having sex out late
when they're not supposed to be
that sort of danger is all that's
already dangerous when you're of a
certain age and so when you add in the
aspect of like oh making these dangerous
decisions can get you killed i mean
those were the remember the prom night
videos from like driver's ed like that's
like literally like that's a that's a
huge part of that and the halloween
translates into that wellness carpenter
put it because he got accused in the
early 80s of being
like the morality police which is funny
because like if you know anything about
john carpenter that's just who he is
dude loves nothing then a good beer a
good joint and like making music that's
fun and he got accused of being the
morality police because a lot of his
characters and a lot of characters at
the time you know on friday the 13th and
nightmare and i'm straight and all the
big classics
he was accused of that because you know
it is characters having sex and drinking
and doing drugs that are dying but as he
put it it's not the sin that's killing
them it's the distraction
so they're not mentally and prepared or
focused on anything else outside of
their being because they're distracted
by
the revelry
whereas lori
is in tune with everything going around
her because she has nothing to distract
her
so i always thought that was really
interesting because the genre
randy even says it in scream it's the
sin factor kind of ran with the idea of
it being a sin and john carpenter's like
dude they're teenagers they were just
i say that like i think lucy's giving me
the thumbs up on this one because i
think lucy grew up also with similar
things but like if you grew up in uber
religious things they made you think
that they're like you're gonna end up
murdered and stabbed the minute you let
a guy go to third base let's go back to
the og because there's a lot to sort of
dissect with that it was so seminal it
was such like this watershed moment with
horror that like it's been imitated now
to nauseam and the only horror movies i
think that are successful are ones that
sort of subvert that but
it's got so many great moments uh
michael i'll start with you what is your
favorite moment from the og um
halloween films a really good question i
mean the whole movie is just so perfect
but i think for me
it's that just that the original really
set the standard for like a good chase
scene and the whole climax is literally
just like a 20 minute long chase scene
and it's so thrilling and scary and
i think it was lucy who brought up
something about like 70s movies just
have a different feel and there's
something about the movie i think it was
maybe because it was low budget or
because the characters and the actors
were so new and fresh that
really feels like you're immersed in the
experience and the way jamie lee curtis
screams help me
after knocking on the next door
neighbor's door and they like open their
blinds and then take a look at her and
are like nope and like just shut the
blinds on her
way she just like
terrifyingly terrifyingly screams help
me as she's hopping off that porch and
started to run back
across the street
is just like it's it's scarier than
anything else in the movie
and he's not even in the shot oh god
help me please
hello
hello
hello help me
can you please help me
please
can't you hear me
oh god
help me please
[Music]
yeah i think for me it's like you really
feel her fear in that moment
yeah and i love that that creepy opening
of the movie where it's it's the
pioneering work with the panavision
camera where you get that first person
sense and you feel like as an audience
we're unwillingly being thrust into wait
are we the villain now we're in the
movie we're watching because it just
it's got that it's not shaky cam it's
not it's not a born identity movie and
but but it's not that set shot either
it's just a hybrid of where we feel
movement and we feel a sense of kinetic
energy creeping up towards the house and
just the way the camera is moving ever
so slightly
[Music]
it feels
unnatural and it feels like something
bad is on the other side of this camera
and it turns out to be a young michael
myers and it just it's such a great tone
setter for the movie we have and the
best part about it is that that movie
was made for
what i think at the time maybe 300 000
that might be that that might be
generous with the budget and so you had
to
be very resourceful and that's a great
indication that we can be resourceful
with shots like this and still be
effective
yeah the camera work in the first movie
is what what brings the audience in so
much and it's so funny i look at a movie
like um it follows um uses so much of
the camera work from halloween that
stocking element that's almost the
entire premise of the film using that
it's hard to pick a favorite moment in
this one because they all kind of string
together but all i can picture is jamie
lee curtis's non-verbal acting in that
movie is kind of
just jaw-dropping when you think about
it because so much of it plays on her
face and the shot i'm thinking of is the
one you i think it even plays in scream
it's the one of her like walking in the
door and she just pushes it open with
this like what's going on
type type wonderment and i think that's
where she sees one of the first bodies
um uh
i want to say i just i picture her
walking in and it's the moment when she
realizes oh this is the i'm in a horror
movie moment yeah when annie's on bed
yes that's exactly right thank you very
much um
that moment is incredible because
the audience knows she's in a horror
movie but that is the first time she
realizes it and then everything just
goes down from there it's sort of like
um the last calm before the storm i love
those parts of horror movies it really
um it's really interesting to see what
she does in that because it's literally
just the score the camera and her face
that makes that whole scene and that
score does it does the opening credits
such a great service because there's a
few types of different opening credits
you get in a movie where you can have i
love the movies that don't even have
opening credits they just bought like
the ultimate example star wars where
it's like we're not going to waste time
and let the audience get distracted
here's the giantest letters you've ever
seen with the most soaring bombastic
score in outer space you're locked into
the movie but then you have other you
have other movies where they literally
treat the opening credits which is fine
where it's like okay the audience is
still coming into the theater we're
going to let everybody just kind of
relax and and get adjusted to their
seats make sure there's nothing sticky
on the floor but halloween it's just a
pumpkin but but you the score is just so
unnerving that you're kind of just
waiting to see what the next thing on
screen is and i love when a the score of
a movie or the opening credits can just
completely shut us up and get us locked
into the tone of the movie what a great
way to
set the pace for things to come when the
original does that without showing a
single frame of the movie yeah this is
very true literally it sets a tone and
you haven't seen anybody you just see a
glowing smiling pumpkin and somehow they
managed to make that smiling pumpkin
seem creepy with just a simple score
yeah and
it's amazing and it's like now it's what
you expect from every halloween movie
and it's and it showed the beauty of
scoring in in horror movies which is
something that was always there
especially in the old monster movie
series like going back to dracula and
you know even the very first jump scare
came from a musical queue because i
think it's in um the phantom of the
opera uh he's playing the piano she
removes the mask and then that's like
literally the first jump scare ever
recorded on in cinema and it's from
scoring because he's playing and it's
like stop and and then it just adds it
to it and i think uh one of the things
that halloween really understood is how
music
couldn't just heighten but how music
could be part and integral to the scares
itself which yeah again now music and
then it tells its own story as well
like people underestimate sometimes how
good a good score really affects
makes a good movie great let's move on
to the to the better like like looking
at the franchise as a whole we kind of
touched on a lot of the big ones we
touched on h2o season of the which um
haven't necessarily talked a lot about
the curse of mike myers but even it had
its moments
um
what
what are your favorite
moments kills overall
from the franchise michael go ahead
god there's so many okay i will talk
about halloween six in the sense that
it's got a really good atmosphere i
think it's got one of the better
halloween atmospheres in the entire
franchise so i think that deserves to
give it a couple few points higher in
fact it's not the worst movie in the the
franchise per rotten tomatoes that's
actually
the way rotten tomatoes rates it it's
halloween resurrection is terrible but
best kills there's some really great
kills in halloween
kills um
that are some of the top for me
um i think one of my favorites the
suspense sequences that leads to a kill
is the hand in the
garbage disposal and halloween h2o i
think that's a really cool moment i
think the hot tub death in halloween 2
is pretty rad
girl cops do it by the book getting it
with the gun
kelly meeker
stuck into a wall is a pretty gruesome
kill
the thing about the halloween franchise
though is
michael isn't jason
you know he doesn't do a lot of
different type of stuff
um the thing i love about michael is
especially in the original
and i feel like halloween kills is the
first movie since the original that kind
of does this
is he's almost like a little kid playing
with a toy
and i love that he's a jokester in
halloween and then they kind of bring
that back in halloween kills and those
are my favorite sequences of the movie
not so much any of the kills but like
the bob kill that's a terrifying kill
and it's so simple
and for me that's where the movies excel
is like the suspense is more integral to
me than any of the deaths
but halloween resurrection has a really
funny death where the girl gets
decapitated with a kitchen knife
that would never happen you know what i
mean so like
that's pretty memorable because it's so
stupid howie resurrection is it that's
the movie that immediately followed
halloween h2o which was the glorious
return of jamie lee curtis and then
jamie curtis was like hey i just did
this movie i'm not going to do this next
but you got to kill me off in the
opening scene
so it kind of
lets us know the rest of that movie we
kind of figure out why jamie curtis was
like i don't feel like being involved in
this but yeah another movie that is
maligned that i feel like as its merits
especially for the time that it came out
is rob zombie's halloween just because
when that movie came out in 2007 i don't
know that there was somewhere else that
you could have gone because we we
weren't in this nostalgic phase just yet
we are nostalgia as our friend corey
jander calls it we weren't there yet
where you start to want to have a
retread of what we've seen
15 or 20 years ago and so rob zombie
tried to make a different type of film
where it got really deep into michael
myers background and sorts of
it's not as an apology for the way he is
but it is an explanation for why he
became who he became but there's just a
heartbreaking kill in there because we
all love
everyone's favorite badass danny trejo
and he just
he eats it at the hands of michael myers
and if you wanted to know look is
michael myers ever going to be confused
with a world-class sprinter no is he
going to be a world is he going to be
the best athlete no he's not that quick
but he got danny trejo so he could get
any one of us yeah
also the one thing i will say halloween
has done mostly because of the first one
and how seminal it is and how many
people love it is it was able to to give
us a lot of interesting debuts but even
more so just weird buster rhymes and
halloween resurrection like real talk we
got bust a bus just like doing his thing
and literally doing the most cliche
brother in a horror movie i'm going to
give you the quote for the trailer
but it's fun
and honestly as someone who had his
photo um on my refrigerator uh all the
way through
probably my second to last apartment uh
we have josh hartnett because of
halloween h2o that was his debut film um
and i feel like i'm a happier person
because that is where he came to us and
you could go back to the world of
hip-hop with halloween h2o because ll
cool j just breaking every
trope about minorities in horror movies
up to that point where i thought ll cool
j ate it twice in that movie and he ends
up pulling through and he's such a fun
character he's trying to write his he's
trying to write a series of novels that
jacqueline colwey would love the
jacqueline
this trashy romance pulp stuff that
jacqueline i know reads i know in
between her true crime podcast that's
what she's doing to get her mind off of
work me so well
my like look if i ever leave this i'm
going to be stacy abrams i'm going to
come up with a really
like funny
pseudonym to write under like penelope
comes well and it's going to be awesome
the thing i love about h2o with l.o cool
j is
his sparring partner is a person off
screen the whole movie and she's
memorable
yeah his wife is really solid in voice
work and i think her relationship is
really cute and funny
yeah i really like h2o i think people
unfairly at the time were i think if
that came out today would be assessed
differently people at that time were
saying it was a scream clone and of
course it was the 90s everyone was
cloning scream of course halloween h2o
clone scream and also kevin williamson
was involved he is
yeah like let's let's let's talk
honestly about the movie
the characters that's one of the few
halloween movies and let's be real when
you watch all the 12 halloween movies in
a row
realize there's a lot more misses than
hits in this series whereas like friday
the 13th i think even though it's the
best friday the 13th movie is nowhere
near the best halloween movie
friday the 14th movies have a nice
consistency at least through like the
first seven or eight where you know what
you're gonna get and you have a good
time that's fair um the thing that
stands out for halloween h2o is every
character is good you care about the
characters and you care about them and
that was something that was happening in
the 90s that the 90s didn't get enough
credit for at the time with the slasher
movie is that they were really trying to
bring you
an era of slasher movies where
okay we're in an error now we're going
to not watch these for the killer we
want to watch these for the people
and i thought halloween h2o did a really
good job of that and laurie strode as
jamie lee curtis in that movie coming
back to the franchise has more on her
plate because now we see what 20 years
of this fear of living with this of
trying to relocate and and facing
alcoholism now just trying to get
through your day and more importantly
your night
living with this thing that is you
always feel like is in the back seat of
your car but she also takes on the role
somewhat of a loomis played by donald
pleasant in the original because now
it's her sort of job to have to
download this information onto other
people's more impressionable minds like
hey this is not just some weirdo that
you have to be worried about this is the
ultimate evil in the universe but i will
give a shout out to donald pleasance too
from the original halloween and from
halloween and pops up again sporadically
throughout the canon he is so good as
that character that we always need in a
horror movie where it's sometimes the
priest in a possession movie or they the
or a nun that shows up and just gives us
a rational explanation for why things
are going on and we feel like as long as
that character is with us we can get
through this because they're going to
use sound logic and reasoning in order
to trap this menace so donald pleasant's
just knocking that role out of the park
as well 100. yeah i was also going to
say too um with what's interesting is
we've talked about when halloween went
cw through the kevin williamson and h2o
uh when halloween goes you know
basically trying to rip off friday the
13th and gets very gory and gets very um
very sort of texas chainsaw massacre
friday the 13th with it um
rob zombie his run it's just so singular
it was it's it has its fans i feel like
it's it's weird almost when i look back
on it what that section was michael i'm
curious your thoughts on the rob zombie
error of the halloween films i uh it's
interesting because you know mark made a
really good point earlier about how like
we were pre-nostalgia
like you think back like you go
halloween 2018 when that trailer came
out and they announced the movie and you
you know jamie lee curtis come back here
like duh why you know this is such a
simple
concept of course they're doing this
this makes so much sense and it's you
know you realize too like weirdly enough
my fiance brian and i have been watching
all the universal monster movies this
month we started at the beginning we're
watching all the way through to the end
you know people are like hollywood's
running out of ideas and they're
retconning and all this they were doing
that in 1940. thank you doing it with
all these movies and it's just a way to
freshen up franchises and stuff
but it's weird because until halloween
did it and star wars did it it was like
and jurassic park did it and all that
stuff you
it was like why wasn't anyone doing this
in the 2000s you know what i mean like
granite they did it in halloween h2o but
rob zombies movies come out in a really
weird era of four where it's like post
911
casual homophobia
casual bigotry just running rampant in
film and in the country
and so it like kind of came in a weird
dirty era of horror
so like they make sense for the time
like even you know i love the texas
chainsaw remake but i think that set a
standard for
the horror movie of the time especially
the slasher which was grimy and yellow
and dirty and grungy and characters that
were foul
and
who better to do that than rob zombie
honestly
real talk he's living in his wheelhouse
drawn out violence and gore too to the
to i mean i think that this is the era
where we might have put the term torture
porn into
into the lexicon permanently and
unsealed it just because some of those
kills just go
on and on i mean you're like okay i get
it octavius spencer's dead
come on
and i will admit jacqueline i am
somewhat of an apologist for the not
necessarily for rob zombie's sequel but
for the original simply because i am
such a rob zombie fan from his musical
abilities that i i love especially his
solo stuff but the stuff with white
zombie back in the 90s too i just think
it's just it's such great metal that i
wanted it to be good and the fact that
he went somewhere else with it i think
again was sort of necessary at the time
because when we had these reboots we
either had them because we let a number
of years go by or it's because we had so
many misfires in a row that we had no
choice but to blow it up and even if
it's not ever meaning to be consistent
look at where we were with batman in
1997
versus where we were with batman once
batman begins came out in 2005. and then
look at where we are now
where do you go from halloween
resurrection like
the whole bloodline thing that they
established in halloween too is out the
window he's just killing a bunch of
random people so it's like well now it's
just a jason movie
you know so it's like where do you go
from that and i think had the reboot
craze not
started they might have gone down that
road i don't know if you've read this
book called taking shape which actually
talks about all the
uh
there's two books there's a original
book and then there's a sequel book and
it talks about they essentially talk
about all the different incarnations of
halloween that could have happened
in post-resurrection they were back to
what halloween h2o helped avoid they
were post-resurrection they were
starting to think about a direct video
sequel until the remake craze happened
so now they of course were able to
remake the movie
but there was going to be a remake at
some time whether people liked it or not
and rob zombie at least the thing that
he did and i'm not a huge fan of either
movie but i appreciate especially with
halloween his halloween too is that he
really did make his own move truly he
was doing something that
all the other remakes weren't doing is
he was following no blueprint
he's following his own beating to his
own
twisted little drum and i actually
respect him for it yeah
i've always been curious to see
halloween too especially what would have
happened
that didn't have the name halloween in
it
and it didn't have a character named
laurie and her name was like jane and
some
like how that would have been
embraced by fans of horror
had it not been called halloween
um because he has an interesting
though he has an interesting pov that's
for freaking sure
and the dude can shoot a movie his
movies look good yeah i think they get
unfairly treated because they have the
name halloween in front of them
but also if you're gonna make a movie
called halloween don't you have to stick
to the ingredients in a way so it's it's
like
or subvert them in a way that's smart it
depends it depends um before we get out
of here
michael what is the scariest moment
or what it what about the franchises
scare you the most like what element of
it really terrifies you is the chase
the the most effective
michael in the shadows the shape you
know when john carpenter refers to him
as the shape and when he's the shape
that's when he's the scariest like
there's
the
best sequences in the entire series and
david gordon green does this a few times
too
uh in 2018 and in the
new newest one kills is using shadow and
light to their advantage
there's that sequence you talked about
it already
where she finds her friends
and that's terrifying right there's no
dialogue it's just her reacting
and that's scary but then the very next
thing that happens is she puts herself
in a corner where she thinks she's safe
but that open door is next to her and
it's complete pitch black
and then his mask just slowly moves into
frame
that's terrifying because that is
literally just saying
you're not safe anywhere like you're not
you think you're alone but you're not
alone someone's walking you someone's
always on your ass and there's some
moments in halloween kills where he does
that and i'm just like those always get
me always
so and halloween kills is the first
halloween movie i've been scared in
since the original wow wow yeah that
says saying something we're gonna get
into halloween kills but before i do
that mark real quick what about you what
about what element of the franchise what
element of the films really scares you
the most the fact that someone had to
teach michael myers how to drive an
automobile scares
the crap out of me the fact that he
somehow managed to take a driver's ed
course because as scary as michael is in
hadonfield illinois haddenfield if you
don't want to deal with michael myers
maybe just move away from haddonfield
and of course that that didn't work if
your name's laurie strode because she
moved all the way to california and
michael again somehow road tripped and
stopped at a bunch of gas stations and
was just high on mountain dew by the
time he got to california so the fact
that michael myers can get behind the
wheel of a car
that is what is terrifying to me and
then also that whole we can lock him up
but is he ever really locked up thing
like if if somebody gets accused of a
crime they're stalking me but i find out
that they get locked up i'm like okay
good i trust the prison system not
necessarily to rehabilitate this person
but at least i know that i'm good for
the next 15 to 20 years
you never feel that way with money he
can get out of jail any time he wakes up
and just has a bad morning he can get
out of prison that is
horrifying yeah i think the fact that
well based on the fact of how much
people love the franchise he's always
coming back and he's coming back yet
again so let's go ahead in our next
section which is normally behind the
scenes let's go ahead and talk about the
latest installment which is in theaters
now uh brian cue the music
[Music]
so michael you've seen it but we're
gonna you know assume that most of our
audience hasn't seen it yet um
what what what were your expectations
going into halloween kills because you
know people i guess involved in the
making of it like how did they how did
they set you up to see it when did you
see it
i went to the beyond fest screening of
it okay um so it had its u.s premier at
beyond fest
and they didn't they didn't you know
prepped me a lot and they
one of my friends ryan turk he's he's
like oversees these movies oh yeah yeah
he um
he's he keeps
close man
he doesn't know anything and it's
i kind of appreciate him i mean i do
appreciate him for that because i still
get to go in completely clean
and you talk about a guy who loves
horror movies inside and out that is
that is ryan turek to it he loves this
stuff and yes and ryan i know i said
halloween h2o is better but i still love
both movies so don't get mad at me
and it's not better i think it just
explores different things in a way that
i appreciate so that's a good way to put
it okay halloween kills
my expectations were low to be quite
honest with you because i thought how do
you follow up the last movie
which i thought was such a solid
especially that third act that third act
is probably my favorite act in the
entire series
um
right up there um that whole sequence
with lori her daughter and her
granddaughter just trapping michael is
epic it's so good and it ends on such a
high note it ends an emotional note for
me i'm a huge fan of these movies and
i'm really cl i feel really a good
connection with laurie strode so i
actually teared up knowing her trauma
was over after 40 years and then of
course they announced the sequel and i'm
like
you know like
of course i'm gonna of course i want to
seek well i don't want these movies to
ever end i want to be 90 years old and
going to the theater theater to see you
know 120 year old michael killing people
but
part of me was like not upset but i was
like i don't want her to die so i don't
want more movies to be made because
someone's eventually gonna come along
and think they need to kill her in order
to close the chapter on her like they
did in halloween resurrection
um so that's my expectations are low
because i'm like how do you follow up
this movie like how do you follow up
this movie that feels relevant and
necessary
so my expectations were kind of like oh
it's michael killing people i'm gonna
have fun and not to give anything away
but that's essentially the movie but for
some reason i don't know if it was
beyond fest i don't know if it was the
fact that it was
500 people for the first time in the
theater since the beginning of the
pandemic for me
i don't know if it's the fact that jamie
lee curtis introduced the god movie
surprisingly no one knew she was showing
up
or that i was literally sitting right
next to ryan turk during the movie i
don't know what it was but i
loved every second of the movie loved it
absolutely
i
had an emotional
reaction to being in a theater for the
first time in two years to be quite
frank you know people might make fun of
me for that but i teared up when the
movie started because i was so happy to
be back in church so i was all in i was
all in from the beginning the theme
kicked in the story kicked in and i was
all i was in i was i loved every second
of it i don't know and
yeah the other person that's really
feeling that same way about the pandemic
and and things starting to open back up
again
is michael myers because he's obeyed the
mandates he's worn a mask the entire
pandemic nowhere in a mask
yeah
see
and and he is so thrilled that
everybody's back out there doing their
things living their lives so he can
murder them joyously i want to walk out
of this theater and say
i want to get right back in there and
just run halloween ends right now
exactly how i felt leaving the theater
my biggest fear for it was like well i
know there's a third movie so like this
is just going to be filler and it didn't
feel like filler
good
you know that's how it felt for me and i
i guess i'm like the
problem with ip today because i say i'm
like enough with the ip but then i'm
like oh you're bringing back characters
from 40 years ago i'm in you know just
watching those characters
roam around was really exciting for me
but this is another reason i liked it
better than 2018.
so we do have those moments this is not
a spoiler but we do have the moments in
2018 again where we're away from the
strode women
but this time you're not with two cops
sitting in a car talking about
sandwiches
okay this time you're with tommy doyle
or you're with lindsay wallace or you're
with marion chambers so you're with
people you're comfortable with already
that are adding to the nostalgia while
also going oh what's tommy doing 40
years later so you're with characters
you want to spend time with as opposed
to
some high school kid that's like
essentially throwing himself on the mean
the main female character dude honestly
that yeah all right that was the one
part about who are these people they're
such red shirts i don't need you
but you need them so that way you know
the main people you care about can live
and we can continue with the franchise
and so on and so forth um before you get
out of here
let folks know what you're working on
what they can be on the lookout for next
and because you are an aficionado of
film and television mostly on the scary
side please give us a movie
recommendation
okay so uh my movie time cut
is in post right now and it should
be
it should come out next year
it'll come out next year we don't know
where yet um
we don't know where it's going to land
whether it's a studio or a theatrical
release or with a streamer um the
producer shot it himself
essentially so he gets to shop that
puppy around
and
give it to the highest bidder
essentially so uh but that should be out
sometime next year and then i am in
pre-production all i can say uh is on a
christmas slasher
that i wrote and i'm executive producing
with um one of the producers of freaky
oh i like that yeah it's another high
concept slasher people when time cook
got announced people are like is this
all this guy can do wait till they hear
about this next one yeah i'm really
gonna say that's all i can do
and then uh because it's another mashup
love that
yeah and then you know um so that is
honestly hoping to be out next year as
well so
my recommendation
is for this time of year is watch the
original house on haunted hill oh yeah
yeah great one i think people get into
the halloween movies or the slasher
movies but i'm going to recommend the
original house on haunted hill because
vincent price
is just so gay in the movie
it's just
been so sexy and just so vicious and
weird the movie's so bizarre it really
is such a weird movie
and it's so fun so that's gonna be my
wreck thank you again michael it was
thank you it was a lot of fun it was a
huge pleasure for folks wherever you're
watching listening to us please please
please rate subscribe tell your friends
that way you can become a member of our
ketchup crew we literally do this for
you it is my favorite part of the week
because we get to come and sort of have
a fun time talking about what movies my
job got wrong
a big thanks to producee lucy tim ryan
brian paris and of course our guest this
week mr michael kennedy and my partner
in crime although apparently not during
sunday football mr mark ellis we never
text anyway that's our rule we don't
curse each other we don't text we don't
text on sunday anyway thank you all for
listening and we'll see y'all next time
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you